[Music]
america went
insane over the weekend that's barely an
overstatement people in their 80s who
have lived in the u.s
all their lives said they've never seen
anything like it
ask an 80 year old this was without
precedent
in the modern era a small group of
highly aggressive emotionally charged
activists
took over our culture they forced the
entire country to obey their will
it all happened so fast and with such
ferocity that virtually no one resisted
it
people seemed bewildered even stunned by
what was happening
statements of fact and opinion that were
entirely within the bounds of reasonable
conversation just last sunday
suddenly a week later were enough to get
you fired from your job and a number of
people were fired
an awful lot happened this weekend for
the next hour we want to assess the
aftermath
of it all suggest what it may mean and
where this country is likely to go from
here
but first we want to give you a sense of
what happened
we're going to begin tonight in
minneapolis that's where the black lives
matter riots first began almost two
weeks ago
as the violence there rage some
democratic leaders in minneapolis came
to a conclusion that
didn't on the surface anyway make
intuitive sense
what their city really needs they
decided is
less law enforcement in fact no law
enforcement so they began to demand that
minneapolis quote
defund the police now the first thing
you notice about this idea is how
unpopular with the public it is
almost nobody in the country supports it
but the activists undeterred kept
pushing the idea
and within days pressure mounted on the
mayor of minneapolis jacob fry
to get rid of his city's police
department this was a problem for fry
fry has greater political
aspirations and this was the last
conversation he wanted to have
so fry did his best to change the
subject with a mix of manic enthusiasm
and feigned empathy fries well practiced
in those areas
here is a couple of years ago with his
preferred brand of community outreach
[Music]
it didn't work then or now
activists wanted actual answers so mayor
frye
tried step two in the process groveling
i've been coming to grips with my own
brokenness in this situation
my own failures my own
it sounds like a sermon give a raise to
the staffer who scripted that
but again no dice black lives matter to
their credit
wanted a real answer to their question
it was then that jacob fry made a fatal
mistake he put himself in a position
where he could be asked that question
directly
here's what happened next
[Applause]
yes or no will you commit to defunding
minneapolis police department
we don't want no mo police
[Music]
what a remarkable piece of tape that is
as a big city mayor
in this country ever been more
thoroughly humiliated get the f out of
here she screams go
well the correct answer to that needless
to say is up yours lady i'm not going
anywhere
i run this city do you doubt that the
entire crowd would have cheered jacob
fry
if he'd said that people always admire
resolve
even when they disagree with the point
of view but that's not what jacob fry
did fry slunk away like a child caught
doing something filthy
the most telling moment though came just
before that when the woman in sunglasses
threatened to defeat the mayor
in the next election what does that tell
you
it tells you that black lives matter is
in fact a political party
maybe the strongest political party in
the united states as of tonight its
members believe
they can reshape this country and so far
they're proving to be right
you can always tell which political
movements are ascendant which are headed
up by how straightforward their members
and sympathizers are about what they
believe
strong people say what they think out
loud they have no reason not to they're
not embarrassed of their beliefs
they think they're winning with that in
mind watch
this clip from cnn this morning this is
the president of the minneapolis city
council
lisa bender bender explains that the
desire for safety
the desire not to for example have your
home invaded by violent criminals
is in fact a sign of racism do you
understand that the word dismantle or
police free also makes some people
nervous for instance what if in the
middle of the night
my home is broken into who do i call
yes i mean i i hear that loud and clear
from a lot of my neighbors
and i know and myself too and i know
that that comes from a place of
privilege
because for those of us for whom the
system is working
i think we need to step back and imagine
what it would feel like
to already live in that reality where
calling the police may mean
more harm is done
hello police our men are breaking into
my home help
shut up racist click that's the world
lisa bender
is calling for how many people watching
cnn this morning as they got dressed
agreed with lisa bender sure that sounds
reasonable calling the police during a
break-in
definitely qualifies as racism
it's hard to believe even among cnn's
audience that very many people thought
that it's so
obviously nuts on the other hand it
doesn't really matter at this point
what the public thinks about anything in
the case of this idea many democratic
leaders are already sold on it
here's former congressman keith ellison
on msnbc over the weekend keep in mind
as you watch him speak
that ellison is now the chief law
enforcement officer in minnesota he's
the attorney general
ellison argues here that it's wrong for
police to bring guns to domestic
violence calls
seriously we send out people with guns
and
and they are there to use deadly force
no matter what the problem may be
if the problem is sexual assault we send
somebody with a gun
if the problem is domestic violence we
send somebody with a gun if the problem
is somebody in a mental health crisis
we send somebody with a gun
okay we know what you're thinking that's
keith ellison kind of an
unfair example ellison has long been a
crazy person he was once attached to the
nation of islam
back then he called himself keith hakeem
more recently ellison endorsed antifa
yes that's all
true but unlike other race-baiting
extremists keith ellison may have a
promising political feature it's very
easy to imagine it
if joe biden wins keith ellison could be
the attorney general of the united
states
at the very least he would be first in
line to become u.s attorney for the
state of minnesota the top
federal prosecutor there what would
happen then
we may live to find out again all of
this probably strikes you as wild-eyed
craziness flat earth stuff
eliminate the police really but things
change fast look at how quickly they
changed just over the weekend
alexandria ocasio-cortez who is a
skilled trendspotter if there ever was
one
is already acting as if defund the
police again a proposal that no sane
person even mentioned in public just
last month
is now the defining civil rights issue
of our time you'd have to be a bigoted
dinosaur
a bad person to oppose it this
is one of those moments this right now
is one of those moments
so if you're an elected official that
for any reason is on this call
i'm asking you to ask yourself what are
you willing to sacrifice
to make sure that over-funded police
departments are defunded
so think about what you just saw
alexandria cortez isn't just
a member of congress she's maybe the
most famous member of congress
she's also a surrogate for joe biden so
a lot is on the line here
ocasio-cortez didn't say that
accidentally she had a reason for saying
it
why did she say that what is going on
here well as usual the truth bears no
resemblance whatsoever to what they're
telling you
think about it for just a second
democratic politicians
control the police departments of
virtually every big city in this country
now they're telling you they want to get
rid of those police departments
if they did that would mean less power
for themselves so right away you know
there's lying going on
democrats do not relinquish power
voluntarily ever period
republicans frequently do democrats
never do so that's the first thing to
know something obviously is going on
here
beneath the surface this has to be an
attempt to increase the power of the
democratic party
because every policy they push is
always and in fact that's exactly what's
happening here
democrats have no intention of
abolishing the police
listen carefully and you will hear them
admit that instead they want to
replace the police take the people who
currently have batches many of whom by
the way
voted for donald trump and swap them out
for new people
people who hate donald trump and hate
the people who voted for donald trump
that's what's actually happening here
and it makes sense
law enforcement is one of the very few
institutions remaining in this country
that the left does not
yet control democrats hate the police
because they don't control the police
very simple remember 35 years ago when
democrats were constantly attacking the
us military
we don't hear that anymore why is that
it's very simple the left took over the
pentagon
no reason to attack people you control
which they do
and they plan to do the same thing to
your local police department let's be
clear
what democrats are proposing isn't some
form of radical libertarianism
where the cops leave and citizens police
their own neighborhoods
no it's the opposite of that what
they're proposing is a power grab
defund the police is a move toward
authoritarian social control
cloaked in the language of identity
politics
already in the middle of a total
breakdown of law and order as we watch
our cities burn
you are seeing new moves to prevent you
from defending yourself and your family
in the middle of it
just last tuesday marjorie green who was
running for congress in georgia
posted this ad on facebook and within
two days facebook pulled it down
i have a message for antifa terrorists
stay the hell out of northwest georgia
you won't burn our churches
loot our businesses or destroy our homes
so facebook has a policy against
violence not the violence
engulfing our cities but the violence
of you defending your family they create
the chaos
you're not allowed to defend yourself
you are in other words and this of
course the point
wholly dependent upon them in the future
the left envisions the only people who
will have guns
are people on their team and that's
exactly what
defund the police really means it means
a woke militia policing our cities
enforcing democratic party orthodoxy
imagine if the diversity inclusion
department at brown university had the
power to arrest you
imagine if the black lives matter
rioters had weapons and immunity from
prosecution
that's what they're talking about
partisan law enforcement and partisan
law enforcement incidentally is hardly
without precedent in fact
it's the rule in the third world this is
an attempt to bring it here
what's again striking is how few
american voters support this
very few polling from just a week ago
showed that only 16 percent of americans
favored cutting funding to police
departments there was
almost no party divide on that question
surprisingly
the numbers were virtually the same for
republicans and democrats
the divide was economic if you make more
than a hundred thousand dollars a year
you are more than twice as likely to
think cutting the police
was a good idea and there's no mystery
there of course rich people live in safe
places
they can afford their own security jeff
bezos doesn't need the police he's got
his own unfortunately for the rest of us
and it is unfortunate
jeff bezos and people like him are the
only ones allowed to talk right now
it's hard to overstate how vicious the
crackdown on free speech and free
thought has been in the last few days
here's the new rule and it defines
everything you are not
allowed to question black lives matter
in any way
full stop that rule has been enforced
without mercy
everywhere and not just in this country
in vancouver a men's basketball coach
was
fired for liking a tweet that questioned
black lives matter
meanwhile a player on the la galaxy
that's the professional soccer team in
los angeles
was fired because his wife said
something critical
online not him he didn't do it his wife
doesn't matter they can the player
anyway
imagine being a high school student
right now high school students who
refuse to show
affirmative support for black lives
matter on their instagram accounts were
shunned by their friends
journalists who asked too many questions
about the group were fired or
silenced again not an exaggeration you'd
think
people in the media would resent this
presumably some do
but almost everybody stayed quiet about
it they were too afraid and some
applauded
the new york times ran an op-ed
demanding that people disown their own
families if their families failed to
support black lives matter
enthusiastically enough
tell your relatives tell your friends
the author wrote that quote
you will not be visiting or answering
phone calls until they take significant
action in supporting black lives
through protest or financial
contributions end quote
got that sorry mom i know you're old and
alone and miss your grandchildren
but we are shunning you until you send
more money to black lives matter
in an environment like this we've never
lived in an environment like this but
you can imagine in an environment like
this
most people get the message very fast
and the weak ones are quick to join in
just like the good little red guards
they've always been underneath it all
here's mitt romney on the march a way to
end violence
and brutality and to make sure that
people understand
that black lives matter mitt just wants
to make sure that americans
understand get through their thick heads
that black lives matter
as if americans didn't know that but
accusing
your entire country of racism turns out
to be a pretty small price for someone
like mitt romney
what romney's really worried about what
all the finance
moguls funding this movement are worried
about is that someone somewhere will ask
the obvious questions
how much have you met romney personally
made how rich have you become
by sending jobs overseas working-class
jobs by charging obscene
interest rates and by otherwise harming
poor and black communities
economically all the basic crimes are
economic
mitt romney doesn't want to talk about
that at all so he marches
and black lives matter couldn't be
happier about it the complicity of
people like mitt romney
gives groups like black lives matter
strength
black lives matter is becoming more
powerful by the hour and they know it
watch this interview from saturday in
which a black lives matter activist
cheerfully admits he may soon incinerate
people with gasoline
i'm a leader of this ftp movement it
means a lot of things it can mean free
to people
it can be for the people it could also
mean fire to property we're hoping de
blasio and
cuomo come out and talk to us and give
the youth some direction
but if they don't the next stop is the
diamond district and gasoline thanks to
trump is awfully cheap
the amazing thing is not just that he
said that though that's
shocking enough the amazing thing is
that he said it on television
live he wasn't worried about being
arrested he's not like you at all you're
still not allowed to attend church
services or go to big weddings
too bad you're not friends with dc mayor
muriel bowser
you could do anything bowser just
renamed a park near the white house
black lives matter plaza and nobody
criticized her for it
msnbc practically sent her flowers
having a mural black lives matter
in huge block letters across three
blocks
leading up to the white house as i said
to you on a sunday
badass move that you that you made the
black lives matter
mural is a representation of
an expression of our saying no
but also identifying and claiming
a part of our city that had been taken
over by federal
forces mayor bowser was
buoyed and gratified by the support she
received from her friends over on msnbc
so she also had
black lives matter painted in enormous
yellow letters on 16th street in
downtown dc
kind of a bold move if you think about
it making a street
partisan imagine a big city mayor naming
a major thoroughfare
nra avenue or planned parenthood
boulevard i think he would say something
about it it's impressive
in a way but black lives matter wasn't
satisfied by it not even close the d.c
chapter of the group released a
statement attacking mayor bowser
for not giving them complete control of
the city's police department quote
this is to appease white liberals while
ignoring our demands
black lives matter means defund the
police
got that black lives matter means
defund the police oh so that's what
black lives matter means no one really
explains that
that's their description and now we know
what intel and pepsi and amazon are
supporting
when they send money defunding the
police
suddenly it feels like all the adults
have gone to saint barts and turned off
their cell phones
who's running this country who's in
charge anyone
yet amazingly some republicans in
washington seem as giddy as they watch
the country go insane
democrats have gone too far this time
they'll tell you we're guaranteed to win
in november
you've probably gotten text to that
effect recently from friends
it sounds good but they're wrong they're
totally and completely
wrong on many levels for one thing if
you care about a country
you've got to try you have an obligation
to try your very best
to protect and defend it no matter who
is helped in november
that's what patriotism is it's not about
you it's about america
but leave aside your moral duty even as
a matter of pure politics
this is a mindless analysis it's a
stupid calculation
bad ideas are like cancer when you
ignore them when you pretend they're not
there when you just assume those
ride it out they spread
most people as we noted currently oppose
defunding the police that's where the
polls stand right now
but will they feel that way in three
months how about in three weeks
in an environment like this you don't
know things move
fast nfl commissioner roger goodell once
opposed mocking the americans like
kneeling
to attack the country as racist now
goodell has announced
he's with black lives matter we the
national football league
admit we were wrong for not listening to
nfl players earlier
and encourage all to speak out and
peacefully
protest we the national football league
believe black lives matter
i personally protest with you
so if this is so good for republicans
explain this why does the latest round
of national polls indicate that joe
biden's lead in this race is growing
and that's not a small thing if you plan
to live here
if you don't want to live under attorney
general keith ellison
so why is it happening maybe it's
because republicans in washington have
decided to sit this crisis
out they haven't bothered to explain
what's wrong they haven't bothered to
tell us anything about what might be
flawed about black lives matter and they
don't plan to by the way
they're too cynical they're too fearful
they're going to pretend like it's not
happening repeat platitudes read bumper
stickers on the air nod
solemnly and do nothing to protect
the country why would voters reward that
democrats by contrast who are completely
wrong and in fact are
leading us down a path that won't end
well
are not ashamed in the slightest of what
they believe day in and day out they
brag about it just today they kneeled in
washington in submission before black
lives matter
we are here to honor
george floyd for those who wish to we
will now
kneel for our moment of silence
nancy pelosi doing something crazy again
before you come for yourself with that
thought keep in mind it wasn't just
nancy pelosi not
by a long shot members of the national
guard kneeled
too so did a group of fbi agents so did
the
prime minister of canada justin trudeau
who just the other day was wearing
blackface
now he's with black lives matter the
police chief of webster massachusetts
went even further than that
he lay on the ground before them in
complete submission
and then things began to spin completely
out of control
not just in this country but throughout
the west as the crowd swelled and the
demand for
total ideological conformity grew louder
this latest cultural revolution became a
parody of itself as they
always do in london protesters
vandalized the statue of abraham lincoln
because what did abraham lincoln ever do
for black people
in boston a mob defaced a monument to
the first all-black volunteer regiment
in the civil war
because black people dying to end
slavery sounds like white supremacy to
us
at around the same time a law professor
from the universe university of chicago
called for an armed coup to overthrow
the president of the united states but
that didn't get a lot of press because
it didn't seem particularly newsworthy
under the circumstances
it was that kind of weekend what is
going on
what is this about even the outlines are
blurry at this point but we know this
no matter what they tell you it has very
little to do with black lives if only it
did
if democratic leaders cared about saving
the lives of black people and they
should
they wouldn't ignore the murder of
thousands of young black men in their
cities every year they wouldn't put
abortion clinics in black neighborhoods
they would instead do their very best to
improve the public schools
and to encourage intact families which
we know beyond a shadow of a doubt
is central to the life prospects of
children
they try to make black neighborhoods as
safe as their own neighborhoods
they would close the payday lenders that
had so much misery to the lives of poor
people of all colors
but they don't even consider doing any
of this they don't even try
instead they encourage theft and mayhem
as if that will help
it will not help
this may be a lot of things this moment
we're living through but it is
definitely not
about black lives and remember that when
they come for you and at this rate they
will
anyone's ever been subjected to the rage
of the mob knows the feeling it's like
being swarmed by hornets you cannot
think clearly
and the temptation is to panic but you
can't panic you've got to keep your head
and tell the truth
tell the truth if you show weakness of
any kind they will crush you
ask drew brees by some accounts poor
drew brees is on his fourth
apology for the crime of defending the
american flag
he decided to apologize now they're
using him as a propaganda organ hostage
tape after hostage tape
at a moment like this there is no
advantage in cowardice in being mitt
romney you think you're saving yourself
you're just empowering the worst people
people who hate you
before you know it you're confessing to
crimes you didn't commit don't start
tell the truth and the truth is this is
a good country better than any other of
course we are flawed but we are trying
unlike
most places and we have nothing to be
ashamed of none of us
immigrants know that best of all that's
why they come here a million new
americans every year
they're not coming because america is a
racist country they're
coming because it's not that's all true
and in our clear moments we know it's
true even the people claiming it's not
truth is a defense no matter what
they're telling you at this moment
this moment will pass remember that all
moments do
when it does we will look back at what
we just saw in horror and disbelief
but if you're honest now you will keep
your dignity
and ultimately you will be very glad
about that
life is not worth living without it